SPEAKER: With almost 500
sessions at Next 2018,
it's understandable that you
couldn't get to them all.
So if you didn't see
Intelligent Internet of Things--
Google Cloud's IoT
Vision, then stay tuned,
because here's the rewind.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
By now you've probably heard--
IoT is a big deal.
Last year, the number
of connected devices
passed the population
of the planet.
This year, it's forecasted
to be up 27% over last year.
If these trends continue,
by 2025 IoT worldwide
will be generating 40
zettabytes of data.
What's a zettabyte?
It's a billion terabytes.
So while IoT is awesome, it's
becoming increasingly clear
that IoT on its own isn't
the be all, end all.
We need smarts, we
need infrastructure
around all of this
IoT data in order
to pull value out of
this glut that we've got.
This is where Google steps in.
As an industry leader in
artificial intelligence
and machine learning,
we have the platform
to make sense of this
mountain of data.
While there's no agreement on
hardware, protocols, technology
stacks, we see some
common themes around IoT
that we're going to be
pursuing through this year
and into the next.
I want to touch on a couple.
The big announcement
from Cloud Next
is that we've developed
a new product that
will push the
boundaries of putting
that intelligence everywhere.
Cloud IoT Edge extends
Google Cloud's powerful data
processing and machine learning
to billions of Edge devices,
such as robotic arms, wind
turbines, oil rigs, smart cars,
cameras, so they can
all act on the data
from their sensors in real time
and predict outcomes locally.
We didn't stop at developing
this awesome runtime, though.
We also announced our Edge TPU,
Google's purpose-built hardware
accelerator chip that
enables lightning speed
inferences on the Edge.
All of this running on a secure
and managed operating system--
Android Things-- and
soon on Linux OS as well.
We're making our Cloud IoT
platform serverless by design,
so that you can go from proof
to concept with hundreds
of devices to productions with
millions of devices in days,
while keeping it
entirely modular.
Cloud IoT Core, our IoT
gateway, is critical here.
To touch on just a couple of
things with our IoT Core--
provisioning.
Millions of devices
can be connected
to Cloud IoT Core with zero
provisioning operations.
We're working with select
secure element vendors
to make this possible.
High-speed, scalable
messaging-- it
will make control
scenarios much easier
where you want to
be able to directly
influence the state of your
devices from the cloud.
Support for gateway
devices to represent
a multitude of less powerful or
less secure on-premise sensors.
All these features
being added to IoT Core
represent a more robust scaling.
We've already in
past conversations
talked quite a bit about how
Google's infrastructure is
built for security
from the ground up.
IoT Core has continued that
trend with solid security
in place, using TLS to encrypt
communication and JSON web
tokens for authentication.
I want to call out something
that we announced at Next.
Our partners over at
Microchip have come up
with an 8-bit MCU that provides
a hardware route of trust
to securely connect over
Wi-Fi to Cloud IoT Core.
Being able to connect an 8-bit
chip securely to the cloud
will change the landscape
of connected devices.
And lastly, I couldn't
talk about Google's vision
for IoT and the cloud without
mentioning all the partners
that we work with.
As big as Google is, we won't
ever have all the answers.
We rely on these
amazing companies
to blend their technologies
with our cloud functionality
to create solutions that
solve the world's problems one
device at a time.
As well as working with
all these great partners,
at the end of May, we announced
that Google's joining the LoRa
Alliance, and we're committed
to working with our partner
network to nurture this
ecosystem together.
If you'd like to
see the full talk,
check out the link in
the description below.
And don't forget to subscribe
to the Cloud YouTube
channel for more great
Next Rewind content.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]